well they're in in the Bahamas there's
there's a slaughterhouse as they
let all the runoff all the blood the
cows and the cows go into the water
right in the water right there huge
tiger sharks are just like um they start
to know it's there that's crazy do you
see them
uh if you tell me another story that
somebody else told you I'm gonna freak
out right because I've seen all these
documentaries I don't know maybe I was
there but the difference is you say a
guy told me what was the question again
so you didn't see it yourself
where what's which part
The Slaughterhouse any of it Tiger's
coming up any of it eating all the stuff
any of it I can't remember to be honest
with you a long time ago uh I may not
have seen it with my own eyes
but I did hear about it with my own ears
this is really the fighter and the kid
come on baby damn let's roll and rock
dude let's roll and rock how was the
weekend Brendan a lot of soccer a lot of
soccer son's in the competitive soccer
league a lot of soccer and I could like
you not very good okay very good and
I won't be very transparent this kid was
12 years old on the other team okay and
the coach I went that kid has to be at
least got a beard he's got a beard you
know what are we doing here and the
coach goes this is how you tell you kids
don't lie about their age he goes hey
Rick goes over to him and the guy speaks
Spanish in Spanish goes how old are you
he goes April 20th uh what do you say
April 20th 2000 or
2011. it's my birthday
coach is like oh you're 13. you're 11
years old yeah yeah and then he went to
other coach coach like no here's here's
his birth certificate on the phone
I don't know I try not to get involved
yeah I mean the kids got cleats and he's
got he's got hair on his legs like what
are you doing the kid was Unstoppable I
mean of course of course and but and he
like kind of sandbagged in the first
half and I'm like he's not that good the
second half that's probably what they do
like hey Jose Showtime six goals excuse
well that soccer program in Europe what
I think is so crazy is that you you will
you get picked and they go you're gonna
go to a special school where you play
soccer all day and then your whole life
is soccer and then by the time you're 16
you get invited into certain clubs and
then finally you know if you make it
you're a pro well bestie and Ronaldo
recruit when they're like six right so
many but so many of them as you know
don't make it so your whole life with
soccer and then you're a good soccer
player see you later but didn't you not
pro
after all that just made it almost fun
almost do you have fun playing no I
dedicated my life tennis same thing
kind of triggering for me you always go
to tensile stuff but I hear you you
gotta similar hold on right
what do you mean to sound like a
worldwide sport yeah sure you see how
athletic it is yeah yeah what what's
what's your problem with it let me talk
soccer fighting football and
everything's in tennis yeah don't play
status right or everybody you play
tennis Everybody Plays tennis rich
people play today no no no no no no no
no that's adorable I don't know tennis
is a huge sport now listen hold on you
live in a van with your parents with
your dad with your coach no and you do
the satellite tours and then you hope
you can make it into the big game I mean
sure for some of them some of the wrist
pants pay for privates and they get on
the tour and do that stuff that's so
adorable you make it no Bubba that's you
don't know tennis that's not true it
really isn't true Tennessee so everyone
is dead broke
would you say tennis
is more of a
middle class upper class it's middle
class not middle class middle class
upper class but nobody upper class
compared to yeah but compared to
basketball I wish there were the case
ball fighting not so much not so for
example Let me Give an example the
tennis that I'm talking about like the
world champion like the Russians the
serbs the cross they don't they don't
come for money the Spain they don't come
for money I'm talking America buddy
right America yes but that's why that's
all I care about guess what but you know
the Russians the Russians the wrestling
don't come from money no but that's
what's their purpose here's what's funny
about that Americans we haven't had a
dominant American champion forever
because they're competing against guys
like nadala come from the Spanish good
guys I mean back in the day Pete sampers
and erotic I'm saying that the majority
of them now like the Russians they do
come from countries see I don't care
about other countries I'm talking about
America where we're born right I'm
talking about a worldwide sport that's
all you're not though see you keep
giving references of Little Billy who's
broke parents put them in a van and put
me in play tennis yeah in America that's
not how it works
America is not how it works no it's not
that's all we care about right what
about the rest of them because you're
American but you keep referencing Russia
I'm talking about we're not from Russia
I'm talking about tennis but you don't
know I'm talking about what it takes to
become a guy who plays on on the level
that these tennis players play at you
play your whole life and you start at
six it's all sports yeah and you but but
but then you go all the way through and
then if you want to be in the satellite
program you're always on the road
following That's All Sport I mean
basketball here kids feet are taking you
around baseball year round and what's
crazy is most of them just don't make
it's every sport every sport every
single sport that ain't special to
tennis yeah soccer football baseball
basketball chance of your kid going in
you're not good odds are against all of
them not good if you're sign up and you
read odds don't do anything
you're not gonna play anything it's true
yeah it's true
but my only problem with that is that
you're so focused on just one thing for
so long that sometimes
especially with like an individual sport
like tennis you're a little bit [__]
because you've been homeschooled you've
only played tennis it's such an
individual sport I don't know that your
social skills are where they need to be
to kind of like fold into the rest of
the world like if you football you have
social intelligence one thing I notice
about football your team player you have
social intelligence because you have to
deal with all different kinds of people
from different parts of the world so if
you go to college too yeah you got to go
to college with like tennis
it's like you don't have to go to
college you you just you just sit you
homeschool whatever and you're playing
tennis yeah and and then you come out
and it's like you know you
spend most of your time you can get a
tennis yeah
yeah and then if you're not or you got
into your head and such a head game
you're like the tennis ball at the club
doing privates yeah that's a ton of time
yeah yeah so retire early correct super
correct yeah very early because just
because they play so much and Pete's
Emperor's retired I was like you know
what was he 45 he was like 34 you know
yeah yeah I hit the hit that's it and
and you play so much year round that
you're a little too into tennis for my
liking though I'm just be straight up
honest and I mean hey
hey you gotta stop right great sport
don't wear a sweater inside out don't
talk about tennis no enough stop with
the tennis we're gonna talk real Sports
give tennis you do you know what the
problem is give it it's dude the promise
right now there's so much going on in
Real Sports yeah you keep going to
tennis and I'm with the listeners you go
to tennis world
you saying we don't have tennis massive
tennis fans you know the only time
tennis here was kind of big was the the
Williams sisters they're out right
they're out we don't care it's fair we
probably don't have a lot of tennis fans
listening she had a few I'm like you
stick with it B I got Andre Agassi
tattoo some [__] like that me
reading my DMs yeah P Sampras is goat
okay thanks man remember appreciate it
Brendan just doesn't understand yeah
Brent doesn't understand he never saw
the way was it Chang came up you know
the chain guy I agree dude you know what
are you gonna do though what are you
gonna do out here dude keep breaking
down the tennis for us we out here we
out here dog we out here we in the
streets dog
we're in the streets uh did you watch
speaking of sports you want to talk real
Sports now or do you want to continue
this tennis [__] well we could talk
bare knuckle fighting that's real
um what do you what's your take on that
sport is it going to grow and what do
you think over I mean it's so new I
think it's going to grow Switzer they
keep putting on cards like they put on
yeah like that was a great card yep who
would have thought Mike Perry become the
face of bare knuckle like he's the guy
yeah
well
if it's an MMA fight it was Luke
rockhold Mike Perry taking him Shackled
all day if it's Michael Van and Paige
versus Mike Perry and MMA May taking my
command page all day but if it's bare
knuckle who the who's gonna be Mike
Perry right he's such a dog he was born
for Bare knuckle is that because it's
it's so different than boxing that guy
Alvarez was like WBO uh world champion
like three times in a row or something
like that Michael Mike Alvarez Mike Mike
Alvarado Michael from Colorado get it
right a real a real pedigree unboxing
and just couldn't fire off because it's
just a different thing uh he's also a
lot older that would be yeah he he was
good uh you know but but it is it's such
a different sport and I feel like bare
knuckle fighting does favor the brawler
the guy puts his head down and just
[__] swings just goes crazy right
because you make one mistake covering up
all that stuff is a lot harder yeah it's
tough to it's just a different type of
game I mean look at Luke Rockwell broke
his team [__] you know he just he was
like I don't want to do this I'm done
but also his teeth were broken he's like
oh this is awful
broke I thought his jaw was broke look
oh he quit he was like no no they quit
my teeth were broke yeah like it would
have got worse yeah everybody's like he
should keep fighting I'm like keep
fighting what are you talking about not
not everybody I was with some people who
said that and I was like [__] off
you want to hear real quick
so
you can check bird and Uncle off the
list some crazy
those little knuckles got me Ralph
Lauren's like let's wait on the model in
a little bit
maybe a beard maybe a better mouthpiece
it's a good fight
it's a shame of that in that way
[__] Mike you tough bastard
congrats thanks to my sponsors thank the
people
I'm not done
some glass bean and stuff
it's impossible it does be nice that's
tough yeah some girls would be cool yeah
it's just it's about Chad Mendes and and
Eddie Alvarez [__] amazing great
great job both I I actually had Chad
winning that fight who should have went
to either or yeah nobody got robbed I
love Eddie yep amazing then Ben Rothwell
and Josh Copeland I don't know who the
[__] been an awful and bear knuckle
it's a I mean it's a tough girl but I
think you know Dustin's out of uh Denver
high altitude I saw him there a couple
times yep but uh yeah
they just like Mike Perry's their
Superstar you know Chad's done Eddie's
still doing it Ben roethlis can be a
problem for people you know they just
need like that I mean my parents they're
the face of the organization I don't
know who they're gonna bring in to beat
him good for him isn't that a great
story good friends he's the best yeah
he's making money he's kind of made for
it but I mean dude found his Lane found
his Lane tough took a little bit to get
there but found it
different kind of dude you know with
Luke it's just like yeah I wonder if
Luke's a dog is just like my question is
I wonder if it grow my feelings it'll
probably grow and I think it'll become
its own art form where people will start
to learn certain things about it like
that are different that just apply only
that how to protect yourself what do you
mean talking about I'll tell you stuff
from what from those yeah there's not
many it's boxing at the end of the day
different than boxing though well it's
different because you're realizing the
the amount of damage the swipe guys wear
gloves amount of damage even though
they're not the biggest shots they still
cut you here break your teeth here like
there's a reason we wear gloves right
I feel it also I'll assume the longevity
in bare knuckle can't be very long no as
far as like if you're like a veteran of
the sport like you're the chance you see
a guy with like 20 fights ain't good
it's a guy who loves the fight game it's
pretty I just told you that and remember
back in the day on fight commands Rogue
and Eddie were like if it was real
they'd have no gloves I remember that
okay okay I remember you said that he's
stupid dude it's just about injuries and
cuts somebody fights can get stopped
from Cuts look at Beck Rawlings it's
like so you don't get a lot of fighting
like you can't no like these huge fights
like imagine imagine that like this
weekend Al Joan Henry sudo get stopped
because I cut in the first 30 seconds oh
well because you're not finding out
who's the best fighter right you find
out who got cuties yeah and then and
then getting some of these like you get
all your teeth knocked out like no
thanks
to Rogan's point I remember you guys had
that debate to Wilkins Point like he was
saying if there was no there's just
literally just bare knuckle but now they
they wrap the wrists so it's like
stronger on the wrist but if they didn't
have the wrap no they break the rift so
they wouldn't hurt punch as hard no I
broke my wrist I could still I still
wouldn't be good though you know like no
I just of course you're gonna get jacked
up but less I think no Rogan Eddie
wanted no gloves and no ring like an
unlimited amount of room I was like do
you hate ratings they're just like there
they go and they're just like 100 yards
away well also like to your point too
you'd have very short careers you just
have like there'd be no no one would
want to do it no you'd have a few
Knuckleheads but as far as like legit
athletes like no no thanks no I break my
hand once I would break my jaw I think
you'd lose your audience I just don't
think people like to do cut through I
think there's a definitely a specific
audience for this and I think it has
Room to Grow they can get the stars but
it there's a ceiling on it for sure
even even I still to this day people
come to me like ah man I like you'll see
it's just so barbaric like yeah right
yeah because at first when you see it
it's like watching TV now show them bare
knuckle and Luke breaking his teeth all
the blood and stuff and then sponsors
you know to get the big boy sponsors I
mean Bud Light would probably do it
they're looking for anything but that's
about it yeah yeah it's true I agree
with you
I agree but that card was fun yeah but
I'll tell you what man when it's not uh
the big names it's tough it's tough it's
tough it's just it's tough I know boy
yeah you know yep yep so did you like
having a chart tree and uh I love that
mikeyan yeah that guy is great which one
both great yeah he's like such an
impressive peace now here's the thing
when we had him on the show last week
and we aired the the episode earlier
this week at the time of that interview
Francis and chatri were going to meet
that day so as this is being recorded
now I think the next day what I think it
was the next day either way yeah it
doesn't matter but so they're meeting
before that podcast they have not met
they met now and the News came out I
spoke to chatri dude it's not happening
now chachu is trying to meet him in
Morocco trying to meet him in Dubai
should I meet him in New York finally
they're both in LA and then uh you know
it just didn't come to fruition it's
just and it's not a chaotery thing it's
more of the demands of Francis it was
very very just a lack of alignment you
know
I I don't know who's going to take on
those terms that France wants it's not
happening I don't yeah it doesn't make a
lot of sense
it's not good it's so frustrating it's
pricing himself out of the market you
know no it's not that I know I know I
know what they offered him it's not that
it's not a money issue the money no I I
didn't mean just money I mean his
demands are pricing that on the market
like you're asking too much
of of too many it's insane yeah yeah
it's I don't know where is that somebody
in his ear or is that him that's him
yeah apparently yeah
well good luck I it's such a shame man
the deal Josh we offer him I've never
seen I've never seen anything like it
there's I mean what be a historic deal
store
it's really guaranteed too does he have
a better deal somewhere is that what
he's looking at I'm assuming he's just
banking on that big boxing fight coming
through but chachu is going to allow pay
him guaranteed money and let him do the
boxing but who knows we we need to hear
Francis on it maybe it
but if it's all things like equal rights
for fighter pay and all that [__]
all right dude is there anything in
Francis where he's looking at
who's in the heavyweight in one
Championship with these monster Russian
wrestlers is there anything in him that
says I don't think I can beat those guys
because if he thinks he's going to fight
and beat the boxers he's looking at I
don't know if that's gonna happen either
what do you mean if the deal is gonna
happen if he's gonna beat him well Tyson
Fury and wait but the two different
things is it gonna happen that's all he
cares about or does he is he gonna beat
him so if it happens he gets whatever 30
40 million dollars there you go now is
he going to beat him as a different
conversation he just needs it to happen
that's all he cares about
um I think that if I thought that 30 40
million dollars was a real possibility
and I got to fight you know one of those
boxers I understand the weight me too I
if if he does have some sort of offer
out there like guarantee where it's like
Deontay Wilder Fury or Joshua then what
he's doing sounds right I would assume
he does you work out right I mean yeah
pretty much every day it's talk yeah I
work out every day you work out for your
body but you know I don't know if you
know this this this this episode is
brought to you by better help and better
help is about working out your psyche
your brain your mind your mind I like to
break a mental sweat too you got to
break well well sometimes if you break
too much of a sweat you need a break
from that uh who's checking in on your
mind you call you talk to your friends
dude it's easy to get caught up in what
everyone else needs from you and never
take a moment to think about what you
need all right yeah you need a little
break yourself a mental break you need
to check in with a professional dude you
want to get balance in your life right
you're talking about therapy and better
Help Therapy can give you tools to find
more balance in your life so you can
keep supporting others without leaving
yourself behind see you bye bye but it's
true if you're thinking about starting
therapy give better help a try here's
why it's entirely online okay it's
convenient it's flexible suited to your
schedule all you got to do is fill out a
brief questionnaire to get matched with
a licensed therapist because you talk to
your friends not the same thing find
more balance with better help visit
betterhelp.com fighter today to get 10
off your first month that's better
health.com and you can switch therapists
anytime for no additional charge
betterhelp.com fighter
bro you got a handful of nuts right now
you got two hands oh dude I'm all nutty
today you're all nutted up dude our
friend sent us a bunch of n let me see
that those are the those are the
chocolate flavor those are chocolates
okay give me the chocolate these are my
favorite I got the bars I get the
macadamus snack bars here what are those
you got the uh these are Daddy's
favorite these white chocolate dipped
macadamias white chocolate oh I love
them so they're so smooth and buttery
you got to be careful because you start
eating them you you go through that
it'll go through and they sent the big
boy packs finally you sent the small
ones forever
tasteless moments then you got the ones
you can take on a journey with you
listen the nutrition experts and thought
leaders are all talking about macadamia
nuts okay they're so hot right now Rogan
they're all doing it they are the Rick
Rubin possibly the best nut for fat loss
okay I don't know if you know this but
they've got they're rich in omega-7
fatty acids which actually supports
stabilized blood glucose levels and
satiety meaning you feel satiated when
you eat you feel Fuller for longer yeah
but what's Brian Johnson say about these
nuts well I don't know all I'm going to
tell you is stabilized blood sugar
levels don't really prevent a post-meal
energy crash they support the body's
ability to burn fat okay yeah I bet I'll
do all this hype on these microwaves I
bet they're so expensive listen world
record epigenetic Age reducer Brian
Johnson includes macadamias in his daily
blueprint diet yeah but are these like a
thousand dollars at least uh they would
usually be a thousand dollars but here's
what you have to understand about House
of macadamias okay macadamias they are
the world's most expensive nut but they
are working with 96 South African
Farmers to make them more accessible
okay their brand is farmer owned and
they can always guarantee the best
quality yeah but they're the best price
to be I bet these House of macadamas
dipped in white chocolate have so much
sugar no added sugar or artificial dude
this is that's about to freak out it
says total sugars one gram yeah how
about that
snack Savory all natural flavors
I mean they are they are unbelievable
man these are keto as well too I'm the
keto kid there's other boys looking like
this right now they also have cold
pressed extra virgin dude look at my
skin I've swamp my face in that dude
you're covered in extroversion Macadamia
Oil it has a buttery flavor so I can't
wait to lick your face and listen House
of macadamias rarely ever give you a
discount but you know what I'm gonna do
it for you guys house of macadamus has a
very special offer to get those nuts in
your mouth use code tfak for 20 off your
order and for a limited time they're
giving you guys a free bottle of cold
press extra virgin Macadamia Oil 20
bucks when you visit
houseofmacademias.com
tfak get your nuts macadamia
um
yeah that's that's astonishing that's
astonishing who knows hopefully France
knows what he's doing you know he's not
you know he's not known for making bad
decisions so maybe he does have
something out there we don't know well
my feeling is it might just be that it's
like okay I'm gonna go box
I'm gonna go make my money there and
then I'll come back to you
but one Championship was a was allow
them to do that yeah that didn't track
it's very interesting it's very curious
I'm
I find it curious yeah I hope it works
out for me I love Francis yeah and like
I said maybe I'm here on one side then
maybe on France side he's like dude
we're not telling you because he's
getting announces we have a guaranteed
to fight insert huge name box or hair
we'll make more money we're gonna do
that and then we'll do the other deals
like those other deals aren't going away
maybe that's what I'm hoping for his
sake Beast crazy right
[__] beast what do you think of his
what do you think of him as a boxer
and I mean not what do you think of him
as a boxer does he have can he make a
fight with any of those guys competitive
that'd be tough it's tough right yeah
he's probably such a difference plus
2500 dog against any of them right I am
plus four thousand against nice and fury
his best bet is to pull it off would be
Deontay Wilder because Deontay Wilder
started late and has the least
experience right and deep Deontay Wilder
also just uses the the right smaller oh
deontay's [__] huge tall but he's
huge yeah yeah but it's huge man yeah
and his reach is stupid yeah yeah oh not
classified as small no six seven bro
yeah yeah maybe six nine actually it's
really tall he has reaches you've been
next to him yeah but but I'm just mean
he's thinner than the other guys but he
also hits that stuff doesn't matter no
you're talking about tech at that level
the size is what everyone's Big B you
got to think about technique so Tyson
Fury complete couldn't be a worse
matchup Anthony Joshua oh man nightmares
fundamentals are great yeah it's like if
it is big and strong but you know it's
more plotting and then with Deontay
Wilder you have a chance to land that
big right hand but again Deontay
Wilder's fought professionals who have
right hands so it's like he you know
he's a minus 1500 plus 1500 white big
dudes monsters yeah I mean you know so
uh yeah you know it's just but for him
the home runs just getting the fight
because he didn't get all the money
life-changing money that's it that's it
and not looking really stupid
oh yeah tough it's tough because you're
not talking about a Floyd Mayweather
Logan Paul fight you're talking about a
heavyweight who cracks crap there's no
there's no way to like fake that yeah
you're knocked out you knocked out but
there is a chance that you know for I
don't care who you are France lands with
that right hand you're [__] 100 it's
gonna be hard to land on Tyson be hard
to land on Josh yeah but sure Wilder you
know a little more risk taker hands are
low yeah shoots from the hip yep
but still he's still a massive Underdog
in any of those fights yeah well his
home runs just gonna begin that fight
and then going back to MMA yep
and one Championship was gonna allow
that so I don't I don't hate on it but I
don't understand I'm hoping it works out
for him no hell no why would you hate on
him yeah I just don't understand I don't
understand that I don't understand I'm
assuming we just don't have all the info
that's right we have one side it's from
the organization we don't have his side
because he's not dumb he knows that's
real money so who knows
yeah the the I don't know if sometimes
you worry you wait that long that's a
problem right the longer your weights
the more you forget about because the
UFC what's interesting to you again is
when I go back to one Championship which
awesome L1 Championship is it Francis
doesn't need the USC there isn't just
one game in town anymore there's another
dude coming in going I'll pay you double
but one Championship doesn't need
Francis either right nobody needs
anybody yeah
and with boxing the way boxing works
it's like you look at Earl Spence and uh
Crawford
you know how long fights take to to
actually come to fruition like let's say
Francis fights the end of next year I
agree
well you you have to remind yourself one
thing about one championship and the
reason Money Matters for them is that
they have a window in the next three
years to get
the best fighters on the planet with
that money and take them from the UFC
over to one Championship it is possible
for the best fights out there and the
most exciting Fighters ultimately to
migrate to one Championship if the USC
is not careful they are going to have to
compete in some ways they're going to
have to match who compete now like that
Soul ditch had an offer from UFC and
from one Championship decide to go to
one Championship okay yeah they're
they're getting guys yeah not just
waiting for these UFC guys to get a
contract one championship's doing their
complete owns the thing yeah sorry I'm a
little sore from yesterday guys sorry
[__] spike ball dude spikeball and
Tennis to get in there dude you're so
hard cattle injury in the shoulder
hardcore dude kind of doing this
throwing my arm extending yeah gets a
little problem here spike ball
daddy can't that's still the thing where
you bounce on the channel yeah Daddy
Daddy throws down but promise that he
can't reach this way without causing
some problems I got a little Rotator got
a little something some here get it
fixed man right here and here you don't
want to sound spikeball no get surgery
and get fixed don't want to be crippled
you want to keep your body where it's
where where it belongs Brennan you got
to get a body gotta keep tight big
George you win uh you went fishing yeah
I went deep sea fishing really and I
told you at first it's fun right you're
like oh this is cool I'm on a boat two
hours later like okay get sick got it
yeah I didn't get sick I didn't get sick
either I caught some big ugly looking
fish look at that is that like a grouper
thing his eye his eyes
too deep yeah when it comes up there's
650 feet deep so when you pull them up
they're oh the whole ladies pop out
their eyes pop out and like is that is
that a uh red snapper chin what is that
I can't tell what that is it's a
rockfish yeah
you guys left from where
um
it was like around Exit like 60. okay
going down here okay so malibuish yeah
flounder flounder yeah halibut and a
bass I didn't catch those but I took
pitch pictures did you catch anything I
caught three of those rock fish it looks
like it was rough man after like an hour
and a half it's like you're just
catching fish and then you gotta track
all the way back it's a beast uh any
seals on them rocks I did see one you
know what that means great white that's
right Brennan oh damn is that Catalina
I don't know you're seen Galileo no
I thought it was Alcatraz but everyone
told me it was no trust me Sam France
right yeah I didn't now the birds are
waiting to steal your car yeah oh yeah
and I got shattered on by the [__]
bird I had to throw my jacket out I was
upset but it was a very nice rain jacket
thank you rain
yeah yeah and I'm allergic to fish so
it's like what yeah so like I just gave
them to my roommate to even touch them
do you get allergic reactions yeah they
but because they're so like sharp and
prickly that any prick on my hand my
hands got all red oh damn and then my
friends went out to eat at a seafood
restaurant afterwards so I had to sit in
the car so uh yeah I was done by the day
I'll tell you who had a rougher day of
that [__] fish he's 600 feet deep
chilling hooks through the mouth feet
just hook through the mouth blows his
[__] eye out as you're carrying him
up blows his liver out and then you pull
them out of the water you can't breathe
I feel bad for him actually he's
probably 100 years old the fish like the
fish like Jesus Christ that's an old
fish it's a medieval torture man he
survives all the other fish trying to
eat them and then he gets hooked with
one eye one eye thank you Alberto for
inviting me Alberto crane Alberto crane
love them wow
um you guys didn't you didn't hook into
sharks no he didn't hook any shark the
guy the guy fishermen in uh San Diego is
like we hook tuna and we hook tuna them
big gray ones they love it yeah
did you go with them
I didn't I didn't because everything you
think is out there is out there see a
dead whale and just giant sharks
you know I was like this guy's pretty
General though Captain Nemo I mean we
all know this great job I'll tell you
right now man you see a dead well
there's a shark sharks biting I've seen
astral Geographic those tuna fish the
blood in the water sharks come with
sharks got it out of there anything you
can think of squid it's in there octopus
okay man
this is Captain from Jaws okay
just general scary it's deep out there
man the water's deep very general well
they're in in the Bahamas there's there
was a slaughterhouse I think it's a
Bahamas
this is slaughterhouse you probably look
it up and uh
as they
let all the runoff all the blood the
cows and the cows go into the water
right in the water right there all the
uh shorts all the huge tiger sharks are
just saying they start to know it's
there do you see them
huh if you tell me another story that
somebody else told you I'm gonna freak
the [__] out right because I've seen all
these documentaries I don't know maybe I
was there the difference is you say it
was a guy told me what was the question
again
so you didn't see it yourself
where what's which part The
Slaughterhouse any of it Tiger's coming
up any of it eating all the stuff any of
it I can't remember to be honest with
you
a long time ago uh I may not have seen
it with my own eyes
but I did hear about it with my own ears
dude I was talking to this one guy he
told me that he saw a ghost and they got
these like devices and like they saw him
and [__] I'm like yeah it was crazy
like his name was Zach bag yeah that's
from Ghost Adventures that's an episode
I remember when exactly I was in there
we had a podcast from Zach Zach's
hilarious he I'd love to meet him
because he's like we may do a podcast
person he goes oh man dude I'm not doing
too well because I'm just exhausted he
was wearing my girl man she this ghost
had her purse like up in the air I was
pulling on her purse she was in a tug of
war and I don't know what to do man it
was just crazy
in your house and all I wanted all I
wanted is to go [__] but Brandon's
like shut up for a second in your house
dude that's insane it was great yeah I
think and I think like the next day we
had Rogan on and we talked about him
he's like this is full of [__] it's like
hey man that's my friend he makes a
business off of that it's about ghosts
but then Rogan had two like uh house
like Ghost Hunters on his show 18 year
olds Cody and Rogan's like it's
definitely something out there Hey
where's that energy with my friend
because he likes to give people rope
that's why I like to do it
yeah there's two like two teenagers that
for YouTube like house ghost hunt well
there's that that's Dan and Colby yeah
they're massive on there there's that
there's that uh thing um in in uh Vegas
it goes Joe Rogan has the Sam and Colby
on then shortly after that Joe Rogan
Ghost Hunters are scam artists
he he had uh uh in in Vegas they have
that serial killer uh um Museum did you
go to that yeah that story is for me
Doug no no but my friend his his uh the
what the Freemasons yeah there are
things right near it yeah and so the guy
who's the janitor keeps swearing he sees
hears things and it's like well there's
so many stories from that place the
place is creepy because people are
murdered there it's just a weird energy
yeah it's it's yeah it's weird I don't
know I don't know anything about that
bad energy it's just you just get bad
vibes from that place
yeah I was terrified I don't give a [__]
the Freemason thing I was talking about
recently there's headlines about the
Denver Airport you told me about this a
long time yeah all the creepy it is it's
nuts yes all the graffiti on the wall
yeah but they also have apparently
Denver airport has underground a hole
underground it's real yeah no that's
real they have a whole underground city
if the if it's a nuclear war the
president goes there is that right it
was there it's somewhere in Montana too
but those are the two locations but on a
Dia like kids when you leave Denver it's
like 40 minutes it's just all like weeds
and it's just oh yeah for miles to get
to the airport get to the airport
there's a horse that killed that's what
several people it's blue with red eyes
makes no sense they killed the actual
guy who made it fell on top of him then
the the people put it on killed them too
so whatever don't use it but they still
use it and then the all the artwork in
there is like children on fire people
holding their kids on fire and you're
like I'm about to get on a [__] plane
they call Lucifer
and you have to see this right before
you as you're going to departures that's
what you see Lucifer yeah that Airport's
terrifying it is it's the artwork is
like yeah I try to avoid yeah
I fly into Broomfield this week
oh my God yeah you do I don't trust you
oh yeah I don't want those bad juju
vibes
at first I thought it was for the Denver
Broncos and it's like why does he have
red eyes
yeah it's creepy
hell yeah it's creepy
it's kind of cool though yeah terrifying
hopefully again I'm playing
huh
all right let's take a little break
because guess what you probably think
it's Black Friday or holiday sale dude
it's on its semi-annual sale right now
you can get the lowest prices some of on
its most popular products you ever heard
of Alpha Brain 25 off kettlebells ten
percent off bam and up to 60 off door
buster deals don't wait too long because
this sale ends May 14th you got about
two weeks that means you only have about
two weeks to take advantage of this
crazy semi-annual sale so what are you
waiting for head to onnit.com slash
podcast ATK
all right stock up on all your health
and fitness Essentials don't miss out on
this incredible deal right now Alpha
Brain are you crazy you have 25 off
Alpha Brain Black Alpha Brain instant
Alpha Brain the shots as good as it gets
Alpha Brain Black Label 25 off usually
give you 10 stuff not today I feel like
Oprah you get off the brain you get off
the brain you get off honor.com
Semi-Annual Sale you got two weeks fam
current events so obviously after
um Tucker Carlson was quote unquote
fired
uh everyone's trying to go after him
right now and then including Newsmax and
another so Newsmax is a big digital news
agency they're willing to give him like
all the power to do his own Primetime
show pick whatever goes on before him
and after him all that stuff like he has
a ton of advantage on that network but
then the thing that was really popular
is the first thing I took across and
said after his firing 80 million views
yeah it's insane how much you guys
powerful wow but here's the thing you
remember when Nate Diaz had his last
fight with UFC and everyone's like oh
he's gonna sign here is he gonna do that
same thing with Tucker dude he can't do
anything for like over a year neither
can Don Lemon oh because of the contract
contract yeah so he got fired no no
because the deal that they signed
they're not allowed to jump to another
Network really like he's out for like at
least a year can he do his own so is Don
Lemon Don lemon's still on the payroll
like he's still whatever seven million
dollars a year they can't do that he
can't start up anything for a while it's
gonna be a hot second dude I didn't know
that yeah interesting it'll be fine yeah
more than fine the question is this next
move is important right
where's he go I guess if you give a [__]
but yeah it's important if you're Tucker
Carlson fan yeah he can go anywhere he
wants it's even be his own thing you
know
it's cool because you like to see
someone just contr take control of their
own career but
dude 80 million views on his
announcement like Jesus mm-hmm
um also today is actually
George's one year anniversary for being
on the show hey well I wanted to take
you guys to dinner yes we are right
we're on dinner tomorrow
[Music]
I'm down if you guys are I'm down I
leave town Thursday it's gonna be tough
tomorrow next week I'm in town all week
though let's do it what do we do next
week all right sweet let's make it
official though do you want to do it
Monday or Tuesday next week what's good
for you B not Mondays Tuesday
let me look at Tiger's hands because if
he has basketball I'm gonna get done
like six cool okay it'd be great it'd be
fun we'll figure it out but yeah I love
you guys thank you yeah thank you George
is killing it thank you you're doing a
great job buddy you're doing a great
[__] job
now I'm forgetting did we talk about
this off air or on air we talked about
it off off okay so Jerry Springer we
grew up watching him he apparently
passed away from pancreatic cancer and
he didn't tell anyone what's going on so
yeah that she takes you quick 79 years
old yeah PC takes you quick PC
pancreatic cancer is like he was
legendary I'm wearing a show back to
that I'd rush home from school and watch
it with all the fights yeah especially
if you miss school you watch it yeah but
then it came out like I think you
started off kind of organic and then
eventually it became just over produced
and it was like all set up yeah yeah but
didn't he was great he kind of went
quiet for a long time it's been it had
been 20 years I made all the money and
was just like I'm good yeah
feels like it
uh but he was a mayor of Cincinnati I
didn't know that yeah I didn't know that
it's queer began in politics yep and
this was off air as well this was nuts
this Source will leave us uh he was they
thought that he was gonna take in either
number one and number four guaranteed so
he told so they and this is always the
risk the Aaron Rodgers thing remember
Aaron Rodgers started to go early and
they filmed them at the in The Green
Room of the draft so with will I don't
remember that oh okay so Aaron was just
sitting there pissed he thought the
Niners were gonna take him then he gets
taken because he was a star in college
yeah Superstar and then so so will they
thought would get taken first but if you
get taken first or fourth they knew he
could fall behind but he thought he was
gonna get taken first so his wife I'm
sorry his girl's there now of course
they gotta film him in the back there
just it's painful to watch he gets taken
I think first pick of this the second
day in the second round and he got taken
by the Tennessee Titans which is
actually a great spot for him because
they're a really good team and he's not
forced to play right away but it's
painful to watch oh yeah of course his
girlfriend goes viral because she's hot
you know
so I know a group of these uh friend of
mine two friends of ours um she's really
good friends with a group of these gay
men all of whom is that her right there
yeah Jesus Christ
Jesus
the hell's going on there all right
there's a superstar quarterback dude
that's good
um it was painful to watch it so so
these these guys they're all gay and
they're from the south and they're all
tough as [__] dudes we play volleyball
and they're all guys and the guy who all
watch sports guys like they're all good
guy goes hey is there where where can I
get the game around here and I was like
oh oh he's like and this is over the
weekend yeah so the game meeting the NBA
Playoffs no no it's not over the weekend
I'm saying this was when we were on it
was on weekend we were playing okay so
he was talking he's talking to his other
buddy and he's like this literally goes
he goes you know I mean and the thing is
you know uh Aaron Rodgers he's going
through the stats of the game stuff like
that and and you know I mean look at the
end of the day you know I I I hate Aaron
Rodger being so [__] hot it's hard
not to root for him you know what I mean
and and he just threw that Danish came
out yeah and I was just like holy [__]
it was it was just like I want to hate
him by one o'clock yeah yeah I mean he's
so hot he's so hot so it's impossible to
root against him you know but at the end
of the day I think that they made a
mistake in bringing him to the Jets yeah
straight guy like what
the last thing it was so funny the
straightest part a gay guy
I'll tell you killing the draft of the
Eagles they're going to get much way
better because they took the risk on the
D tackle from Georgia who's was the
number one Prospect but he had a little
bit of a dicey background so they took
him what's funny is when they took him
that for whatever reason this analyst
NFL analyst goes and he has a big dick
what on air what I think she just [__]
up no yeah
yeah it was obviously
his past rush is second to none he's a
big dick I mean
is that what that this was about
like
hold on so Jalen Carter
here it is
let me uh rewind this one so she's on
NFL Network
[Laughter]
big guy I wonder what she was she was
like freudians thinking about his dick
yeah big dick big guy
and I wish you'd go like this yeah
that's what I meant big dick big guy did
like and she goes is she a big big guy
she goes on no no I've seen it nothing's
massive no yeah no it's delicious no
I'll say it again yeah yeah delicious
big dick big guy the big dick yeah big
dick black delicious no I meant to say
every word of that yeah no I'm a fan all
right so how funny is that just [__]
up just power through it too Carter um
big guy amazing player great team man
I'm gay and at the end of the day the
guy is really probably the best asset
that comes
Dylan Carter Great Run Stop big black
dick and the thing about him I like most
besides that big black dick
at least you just power through it she
was like oh she was just powered through
it
but yeah Eagles took a chance on him
he's the best player in the draft and
there you have a superstar D tackle so
they get him and they get the Lineback
from George's problems yeah
so this is a
key Keon White's reaction to being
picked in the draft he didn't want to go
Patriots
White
defensive ends Georgia Tech
[Applause]
all right
he's my 28th overall player so
he's he's pissed
he's 40. he does look older yeah for
sure why was he not happy you probably
want to get another team he thought
another team was going to take him they
went to the Patriots how old is that
gentleman
I mean he's a senior in college that is
crazy he looks like he's retiring yeah
he really does he was pissed going to
the Patriots he's all damn or was he
just kind of overwhelmed no he's almost
like 24.
that is crazy
dude he's six five two what something
dude how about my [__] uh Denver
Broncos got the only white cornerback in
years from Iowa talk about a unicorn or
what in 2023 this white boy plays at
Iowa and he ran a 4 4 40. he is a baller
what Denver weather cornerback what oh
come on
there is Riley Moss Riley Moss I'm gonna
buy his jersey talk about a [__]
unicorn you know the odds of being a
white cornerback making it to the NFL
and this boy can play man really hell
yeah you don't say oh dude how how
racist would you say you are why is that
racist how's that racist look at this
kid let me see him in the cut in the
combine he's a looker good looking kid
well he's 45 too so oh no no no he's 45
no that's Prince Charming from Snow
White is Prince Charming from Snow White
no no no hold on why not hold on nobody
is he's the he's the evil guy from Shrek
he's the prince from Shrek bring that up
Jen evil Prince from Shrek same face
same jaw hit it there he is oh Lord
[__] douche same guy
[Music]
if there's a white guy dominating rare
in the 100 yards dude that is perfect
but they're spot on homeboy that's
incredible by the way that's crazy
that's crazy thank you sir that's a
crazy comparison oh my God obviously I'm
moving that's yours that's your best one
yet no I've done it that's amazing you
as old as Yellow Bastard from Cincinnati
I don't like that I like what do you
mean it's spot on that's good that's my
gift be cool man I have a pen here I
think it's serious
um no no it's not racist it's just if
you if if like tiger he's you know he's
half Mexican half white he's like Dad
don't play corn I'm like okay I mean
already you're allowed to make the NFL
or what one in whatever 10 million as a
white corner
uh the last white corner by Jason
seahorn Jason I can tell you I think it
was Jason and they moved him to safety
that was in the 90s sir yes sir okay and
then you saw what happened when he tried
to cover a really good black wider no no
no no no don't do him like that no no he
died he was all pro for a second yes but
Terrell Owens was like hey get out of
here let me show you well Jason's
Hillman was obese in his prime also that
was one of his roles he's like hey yeah
yeah but Terrell did that the black
white Chinese doesn't matter it's Trello
Owens yeah but still Jason is a beast
Jason dude you know how much of a freak
you have to be forget NFL freak just to
play cornerback at a big school a Big
Ten school yeah he runs a 4-4
let me see that kid again let me see
that kid he's skinny though small who's
a cornerback be right
well they're getting bigger and bigger
no another Corner you'll be so fast it
doesn't cost him out you've seen what
the other Corners look like that went
before him all Corners are skinny yeah
they have to be fat that they have to be
so fast
it's got a job his numbers are nuts his
combine numbers are really well they'd
have look at this [__] lace you know
yeah you you know how special that kid
is to hey just to play division one
starting quarterback is a white boy
you better chance to make you the NBA
it is kind of crazy huh he's nuts he's a
[__] unicorn total outline we gotta
celebrate this guy it's not a racist
thing he's a total outlier and that's a
good example of white power and I just
think that over no Jim were you not
excited when Jeremy Lin started balling
for the next of course dude because he
represents you this guy represents me
how's that racist I want to stop
everything right now generally it's
Chinese Asians though no Asians no and
for any age Yao Ming that shirt for Yao
Ming but Jeremy Lin a small dude from
[__] Harvard yeah balling out for the
New York Knicks Insanity a white guy
playing corner I don't think black
people should be able to play in the NFL
I said it oh wow
no that's racist I just think it's
unparent yeah
um I'm gonna buy his jersey
well I hope he makes tea oh [__] that's
well you guys still up in the air oh
yeah you still gotta make the team oh so
you get drafted and you still got it you
got a team yeah he was like a
representative of Asians too yeah I had
his racket yeah Michael Jackson yeah
small guy too that is reacting like all
test Players let's just put the the
handle on my [__] right right you
know tennis wait what did you say
nothing keep going chin
I'm sorry sir
excuse me good run defense big black
dick I mean
that's so funny Madden shuts down
Facebook watch Originals group yeah all
their different the shows they had on
Facebook watch including red table talk
which was like a hit it was a massive
Five Seasons Matt but also five seasons
like it's ran its course it was a big
hit yeah massive is that Grandma hey
hold on yeah this is earthcon big hit
his daughter is gorgeous okay dude
that's not what this is I think she
doesn't shave her I don't care so she's
beautiful though yeah isn't she yes sure
of course and then that's crazy that's
grandma yep that's grandma mom and
daughter yeah
Yeah man so the point is where is
Grandma from is Grandma Jewish uh no
Grandma's her mom so the thing is with
the story who gives a flying fox no I do
but the red table talk it's ran its
course so but Will Smith ain't the only
one losing jobs huh like she was the
Catalyst behind all this [__] so of
course you should lose all her [__] if
Will Smith is losing his [__]
uh can I see where her Adrian Banfield
Morris comes from She's
she's waiting something she's from
Baltimore
yep keep going Jewish I don't know you
want to know her just ethnicity yes I do
yes I do
I do indeed let's see if this what
nationality is Angela
former dog
American
uh-huh
it's hidden
who are but it it said uh I saw
something
let me go here real quick
this was American
well no we know she's American Born
Baltimore Maryland
yes
let me see what her parents are I I find
type in ethnicity
pink Jaden Smith to me is um has always
been very attractive to me I think she's
just she's been a nightmare of course of
course she's attractive
yeah that was a hot take [__] though
some girls get under my skin she's one
of them
in a good way but there's not much
should also be a nightmare she was
birthed at the age of 17. what the [__]
it's a stupid article
there you go there you go
she's a Jamaican son on her mother's
side what is Beijing Beijing is like
what uh Rihanna is
really that's Trinidadian
Creole I was African well let me just
stop on the brakes on the podcast fully
real quick hold on let me just let me
make sure it's a screeching halt for you
and let me just get the break there
there you go there you go no let's Hey
where's
it again
this is you on the break on every
podcast
[Laughter]
her mom and dad from
Etc and then 20 minutes chin uh all
right let me try to
okay well yeah it says here
um she's from the Caribbean [__] man
Caribbean uh what specific island chain
can you type that in okay let me just
I'm sorry
sorry buddy sorry guys I go off off the
subject oh [__] that's funny your Red
Tails I'll get canceled
yeah
another news does it go anywhere else
and other news she's half Haitian does
it go anywhere else no it's over that's
it no they're gonna they're obviously
gonna shop to hit show so it's a big
show they have big big ass names on
there so it's I didn't know that's where
it was you get it on Facebook Facebook
red for a while where's like I think
subscription I thought it was on Netflix
or some [__] no he's stupid huh yeah I
don't watch it you'd see it on Netflix
you know shut up
all right um yeah what else you got dude
ah God quick one this is from last week
as well so remember when we heard first
heard about Stefan Bonner's death yeah
they said it was a heart condition it
turns out it was accidental overdose on
fentanyl which a lot of people die from
fentanyl I think some most people assume
that they still want to say you want to
be respectful of the family it's [__]
tragic is a baby girl it's horrible man
horrible yeah his house burned down too
all that stuff yeah yeah yeah terrible
yeah
um fennel [__] takes out so many
people it's so many so I mean if you go
through the list of famous people's
taking out Mac Miller prince prince uh
uh
David Bowie wait Prince died of fentanyl
David Bowie yeah what was he what was he
doing taking the fennel drugs right I
think yeah I think it's just they're
taking it but they didn't he wears high
heels I didn't know he did drugs
actually I thought he was taking stuff
for his pain medicine Daddy yeah Prince
I don't know hold on yeah so fennel
overdose
they were poison Federal laced drugs so
it could be he's taking something else
with that fentanyl's in and then Phantom
is so powerful that it would kill you so
he was taking drugs yeah dude I think a
lot of dude a lot of people hold on
you're telling me this famous rock star
did drugs Brian look into it chin
confirmed that no I thought hold on hold
on let me he didn't drink hey Chin Chin
can you look up what exact drugs friends
died from he died I didn't know he did
drugs though yeah dude a lot of people
take drugs hey hold on
still drugs though drugs though yeah Mac
Miller just oh yeah that's all right but
what I'm saying was that a prescription
drug that Finn if uh Prince took that's
what I'm saying dude he did drugs hmm
I don't think so
hold on George you just sent me
something so you think Prince was a
complete sober I that's what I he was
always known to be sober
it takes to kill you oh that's okay
that's what George is saying he's that's
yeah that's how small of it is and
they're putting it because it compared
to a penny that's a tiny little static
opioid what oh that's how tiny yeah see
you know what the myth is if you touch
it you die like you're running cops
pretend like they touch it and that
that's the face debunked yeah yeah I
can't absorb through your skin wow
well that's a tiny amount
that's a [__] scary tiny amount yeah
yeah that's I mean doing cocaine now
you're really rolling the dice Russian
Roulette I gotta stop doing blow every
night yep yeah look into it especially
after before we start the show I can't
believe you thought Prince we should do
all we should do a shitload of blow and
try to do this show that'd be really
interesting if it was pure blow I would
do it with you guys if it was pure blown
it was like nothing you know no fentanyl
whatever I'll just be worried we'd just
be talking over each other even more
yeah interrupting yeah doesn't make
people good blow is just turned you into
a kind of a little bit of a rat kinda a
rat yeah you start snitching on each
other she's looking around for more
you're fun but did you have fun did you
have fun no did you have fun did you
hear me up all night did you have fun
what is that Holy shnikes so don't stick
chubs oh yeah Dana White posted this I
don't because the bar looks insane to me
so you guys know about it I have no idea
I already bet okay uh that's a lot of
45s that that could happen for sure
so it's apparently seen a bar really
yeah 610 pounds squat
which I think I scored 610 pounds I've
seen the bar flap like that a lot of
people commenting on the bar yeah that's
that's a lot of weight on them that's
and I hate how the guy's hands are so
like at least a little bit further away
I'm [__] kidding that he's rapping
with this
what are you saying chin the the uh
spotters
no no a little further away just tough
because when that goes south you got to
be out here but I mean just I want it to
be more like clear yeah but that's doing
nothing with that weight like the way
like yeah they don't need to touch
without exactly so there's literally
just touching it's not doing anything
yeah but just it's a bummer I'd rather
see him like a barga limp dick who is
that guy I'm sorry uh Chubbs is a
running back for the Cleveland Browns
what it's just so much weight 610 squat
yeah that's crazy [__] what is he
what does he weigh 210
um let's see it's not like he's a giant
shorter though
227.
511.
Georgia player that's right stud
he's bawling last year he's been balling
there's 1500 yards last year
um so insane how many more current
events you guys just a few more a few
more let's go here real quick so so this
girl she was kicked out of a Brazilian
Supermarket because apparently she was
wearing stuff so that's just too
provocative too revealing I'll be the
judge of this I'm a victim
oh my God so that's her
at the market I mean first point anybody
who kicks her out of the market for that
should be arrested for themselves yeah
that's the front side of it
but she's obviously doing for attention
I mean of course she's the only thing
also I hate those cards so yeah wide the
card is anybody else think about the
card
S
I mean that's two that's all I'm
thinking about it
cars those cards just go on if you're
into if you're into that hourglass
figure with those impossible breasts in
that ass I mean
she uh she got kicked out of the store
for that she got kicked out for it yeah
so unfair
that's that's that's all players she
looks like she can squat seeksando Jesus
Christ that's that's impressive you're
too light in the ass B
um I am but I it never stopped me from
trying Brandon I that ass is eating that
thong isn't it
look she's uh she's cool she's healthy
yeah
can we look into her parents and cousins
ethnicity please I would say this if
you're a man I don't want to have sex
with her you're gay
yeah she's Brazilian oh oh she's the
slurp slurp yeah
I wonder if they kick out in America too
Brazil's pretty loosey-goosey oh yeah
well there you got a wagon on her man
that's a wagon little wagon it's a wagon
get that dump truck that's a wagon that
shooter got a critter that Critter got a
[__] damn
yeah
um
Georgie you found this one this is
pretty crazy
freaking super cool salamander video
oh damn look at his hands looks like
Brian Cowan's skin hey not anymore
not a plant eater look at it damn
not an animal to cuddle that's a
salamander with some Chompers yeah 47
inches tall oh yeah giant has a wide
Chinese face
[Laughter]
it does but I mean it's a Chinese face
when you think about wide faces when did
you do this Chinese though so the
podcast was over
well the Chinese comment when Brenda was
watching a salmon and said he had a
white Chinese face here's the thing
that's a Chinese
but because he lives in China compared
to Salmon if I said why German it was
when he compared to Chester Chinese
person
he's in China the ones with spots in
their face
and it's Chinese now if he was North
America I'd say wow he's a weird
American face China chin was
excommunicated from the ocean Community
I think at the same time when he started
this show
after crazy rich Asian yeah and
to say that I had nothing I I I haven't
talked look Chinese salamander dry
Chinese face right well
again there it is and he has psoriasis
yeah so I want to say for the record
I've never seen a Chinese person who
looks like that even a little bit so
I've seen some Americans flat faces if
he was American I'd say American
salamander now I understand it he's a
Chinese salmon that's where he's from
Brian yes that's his origin look when if
you scream the n-word and then you say I
have some black friends it's not going
to get you yeah yeah we know this
all right okay there goes
oh what's this this is a road rage
incident in Coachella is Coachella over
almost over all my buddies go to it yeah
I mean it's over now I'm missing out on
anything you've never been to Coachella
bee all these years I never have
um this reminds me before you even show
me this was there was a restaurant
called Joe's like you might have eaten
there a long time ago on Abby Kenny it's
where oh yeah it's where you told me to
take Joanna on our first date and they
were closed There You Go Bubba you
remember I go I got this great place my
boy recommended I just pull up and and I
she's like it looks dark I'm like nah
girl it's open
close I'm like okay uh we just went like
walked up to the next restaurant so
Joe's is a great restaurant owned by a
chef who is amazing who had a really bad
stutter so he was kind of quiet and he
found his [__] food and Joe's had a
manager there that was pretty stable in
the community and known kind of a guy
great guy young guy knew how to run a
restaurant and he went to Coachella
and
and he got in some kind of a road rage
thing with somebody he got in a fight he
had a bad temper
anyway it comes back and that next night
Sean he got in his car somebody rode by
on a bicycle and shot him killed him
damn the 45 and then they never caught
the guy ever coach Coachella man I know
and that's what I think about because
yeah he he they didn't know what
happened they could never figure it out
and they think he had this road rage
incident outside in the parking lot and
they knew he worked there and they were
and while this guy he probably forgotten
they [__] with the wrong dude yeah who
figured just followed them so it's a
cold case yeah yep are you asking me to
investigate this I got a lot on my table
right now I sure am that's horrible can
you imagine me the family though like
yeah he shot and killed like you did
like you got this car at the end of the
shift and the guy just rode by on a
bicycle [__] yeah late night so nobody
no Witnesses
back then two is before everybody had
cameras everywhere what happened with
this guy chin uh so this is from KTLA
I'm sure you guys watching every morning
yeah man every morning baby so this is a
uh with Dallas the weatherman Dallas
Dallas Rays I went and saw a one
weird what'd you say I went and saw a
one-man show he wrote oh you know who I
went to Monster Jam this week on my son
and we're doing like the whole VIP thing
because we had to ride in the monster
trucks which is insane remember the guy
from uh bring this uh actor up Jen
because B he said he'd give your your
first gig on Mad TV
he was in that movie Road Trip
actor smaller guy Brecken Meyer uh bring
him up you everyone's gonna know him if
you've seen road trip he's been a bunch
of stuff admire yes yeah yep you saw him
there yeah how's he doing he was great
he was with his kids I was with my kids
and he goes oh he goes uh you know Brian
right I'm like yeah that's my guy he's a
God tell Brian I said what's up I love
Brecken you know I saw uh
Adam Martinez Too you did that dime
piece of the best man yeah is he in
these shots Adam Rodriguez Adam
Rodriguez yeah I love Adam that's great
yeah Breckin how's he doing man is he
working what's he doing he didn't ask
him probably no look at him he's there
with his kids having a good time I've
known Brian look at that I've known
Brecken for so long really good guy
great guy funny he's been compared to
his looks as far as this looks uh to
Bill Maher I heard that yeah better
looking than building yeah but I mean
it's like similarities nose
bills noses yeah different much better
he's a handsome guy
yeah he's been working since he was a
little kid yeah you'll still Brian said
what's up yo how you know Brian's like I
gave him his first gig at uh Mad TV is
that is he oh look at that he has two
kids oh wow really nice kids amazing
because he was married before with kids
and then Mario Lopez was there with his
kiddos huh
it was fun man amazing
good friend
Jessica Biel was there Chen nice you
like her she's she's beautiful yeah
ridiculous
who's the guy in the middle he's the
driver for the Monster Mutt yeah right
cool
you kids are gorgeous
gorgeous
look at him
cuties nothing nothing uh bossy like
tomorrow
well Boston's has your size you're as
big as your head he's a big boy we have
the same head size it's crazy
yeah that's a three-year-old
I'm not sure why George post the same
picture twice and I'll take a warm hand
to his face when we leave here
what else you got Jen uh let's go let's
see
oh okay so the Hodge twins have been on
the show before I wasn't part of the
show back then but they're kind of
saying like there's something might be
fishy with the whole Demar Hamlin stuff
like he was potentially faking
this stuff he definitely wasn't faking I
know
they've gone a different direction I
still like both of them I I don't keep
up with other stuff I know they're kind
of pro right guys now I don't keep up
with a lot of it they start off as like
goofballs like comedy YouTubers we have
them on the show remember they're
entertaining for sure but yeah I like
both of them I I don't know what they're
up to these days but let me just play
this real quick okay so this is what he
said when uh when he first interviewed
him
physical condition can run circles
around me right now
all right what happened to you
sexy I'm sorry what say something
say something
yeah
boom
um
oh
is now
[__] you again
but my feeling is he might not want to
stand in because he thinks it is the
vaccine yeah he had a booster so he he's
gonna try to not saying because if that
there's no win for that but also the NFL
and you know who knows who else got in
his ears like yo man you cannot paint
this narrative that whatever shot you
got caused this problem because it's
gonna [__] our mission here yeah
whatever here's a certain amount of
money he thinks he feels a certain way
about something he can't say anything no
he's not a doctor he's not a scientist
the Huntsman said like when have you
ever seen this ever in NFL history how
could it be the first time this has ever
happened if it's like a thing that could
happen well no I mean it did look he
didn't fake having a cardiac event I
promise you he didn't no no because
they're not saying blame it on the what
it to blame it on the hardest like the
condition the impact because the NFL's
been around how long yeah and this has
never happened before what's the common
denominator here that like what's the
only thing that has changed that he did
that result in this result there is a
chance that we we know that myocarditis
which just means inflammation
but marketers of the heart
can be a side effect in some men
uh when they take the vaccine that that
I don't know what it's proven that he
got the vaccine shortly before that
event he got maybe then large heart
added with the combination of getting
the trauma to the heart causing that
could be could be who knows yeah it is
weird
whether that's true or not I find it
Instinct that you're not allowed to
bring that up
you understand you don't realize how
powerful the NFL is yeah like I think
it's interesting you're just not allowed
to even talk about that because people
don't want to create vaccine hesitancy
which I understand I understand I don't
understand because that's one of the
problems you gotta let them let people
know because this happened to the guy in
his Peak physical condition can happen
to anybody if that is the actual problem
that's the question though so yeah
commodio quartus that was the thing
that he's that he's claiming yeah that's
good and that by the way is possible
that's been around way longer than the
vaccine so that is a thing right no it's
a thing hey B it's a thing it's never
happened that's what they're saying of
the NFL yeah but the NFL is not an
impact sport
even back in the 90s they don't do it at
full speed yeah especially in the 90s
but also there haven't been a lot of
hits in the NFL over a long period of
time yeah so it makes sense that this is
the first time it tracks is that what
you're saying yes I'm with it okay
that's what's this gin okay so this is
the road rage incident caught by I think
two different cameras so
basically it was all because of someone
wanting to get in and the person didn't
want to let them in their Lane because
they were super packed yeah you know
it's like a packed event sure so this is
what the guy did
this guy threw a bottle glass bottle
into this window well there's a girl
episode of road rage has excited music
fans head to Coachella
hold on we fast forward This Together
broken glass floppy traffic so I saw
everything happen for what it is only
because he was actually harassing
forehead so this guy at least this guy
saw it happen behind him it wasn't even
his car but he walked out to confront
them to you know defend the the people
that got hit hey pause it for a second
this guy no I understand in general is
this news right anybody died no right La
has bigger problems right now right
smash your window it's terrible is this
news
when I see this stuff though KTLA has
changed it pisses me off though I'm like
can you imagine if that happened to you
you're going to go out there and you're
gonna you're gonna fight him right uh
probably not if I'm gonna go oh this guy
probably has a gun too but I mean if
they smash your window you're gonna just
like leave
yeah knowing me okay I think I don't
want to leave
but in that situation I'm gonna go this
guy's dumb enough to do that he probably
has something else he could have a
that's how people get shot I'm gonna
call okay get out of here like let's go
and then the guy goes back bye-bye his
buddy laugh in the back yeah that's the
guys okay I can't imagine I would just
literally jump out I'd be pissed yeah my
natural reaction would jump out yeah
then if I see a gun out run exactly if I
see a gun I'm done I'm like whoa dude
it's Coachella take it easy yeah
anywho I think that also there's a
chance they didn't expect the window to
break so it's a gang it's like oh no as
far as they hit it yeah
let's do this one real quick so I try to
look at all the details it's very
complicated but yeah Pros who used to be
in the Fugees yeah
he's apparently considered a an
unregistered foreign agent for China
[__] and then uh even Leonardo
DiCaprio had to do something in court so
they have ties to the same Malaysian
businessman right but Leonardo is fine
he's good to go but apparently this guy
Pros he has some sort of connection with
money and then also like representing
Barack Obama putting yikes they gave 800
000 to the Barack Obama Campaign that's
nothing for Brock that's a lot of money
yeah as much money he's able to give the
fujis were big but maybe he but this guy
he's like the least famous of the food
he might be a producer he might be a
writer he might be yeah he might have
wrote all the [__] money yeah but he's a
Chinese spy
um potentially he was involved in in a
foreign agent in from helping promote
information
that was that was uh somewhat I guess
beneficial to the Chinese government on
to to influence the US government during
both Barack Obama and Donald Trump's
presidencies Michelle's defense argued a
mixture of poor legal guidance and
desire to make money land him in a bad
situation we're extremely disappointed
in the result but are very very
confident the ultimate outcome of this
case
this is not over sounds like it's over
Michelle testified that in 2012 low paid
him 20 million in order to secure a
photograph with Obama whoa whoa I'll
take 20 mil per pick yeah what
show you some of that money to get his
friends into the campaign fundraising
events but said he was not aware that
was illegal prosecutors also accused him
of using straw donors to channel 800 000
oh so it wasn't his money even though he
got 20 million low himself already faced
criminal civil charge in the US related
to one of the world's biggest crops in
schemes the so-called one MDB scandal
the businessman has been as tough as The
Mastermind behind the embezzlement of
billions of dollars from Malaysian
Sovereign wealth fund he's claimed
innocence there oh this guy's a bad guy
of course he's sentenced to 10 years in
prison
plus you said that it's the separate
scheme Michael took 100 million from low
100 Mil
Michelle was accused of advocating to
extradite the exact exiled Chinese
billionaire
he keeps blaming everybody else let's
get a bad guy
yeah it's too detailed this let's try to
read it
like real inroads to the Obama
Administration and then foreign agents
said we'll give you money if you
actually help us yes uh so it's
basically a business deal and Michelle
was probably like I mean 20 million
dollars I'll get you in with Obama I'll
get you in I don't know I guess it's
illegal but damn but what about the
other part all he's doing is getting
cameos with him
future cameos oh all he's doing though
is getting like a picture for this guy
with Obama
and then who helped finance Marshalls
and then and then he's like hey get the
Trump Administration to back off this
investigation
uh Leonardo DiCaprio mentioned low uh
mentioning a desire to donate to Obama's
campaign here's where Michelle [__] up
talk to him talk to our lawyer and say
am I breaking the U.S laws here is this
major is this major Espionage or
something and then they would be like
yes and then you just don't do it I
never forgot he knows what he's doing so
Mike he's too much of a track record
when I first moved to LA well not you
know I've been here for whatever but I
found out that in Nevada you can have
um you can basically claim taxes place
of business have to live there six
months in a day so I call my my business
managers that time we've been in the
business forever and I go hey I want to
buy a tiny place in an office or
something that's where I have an office
and just say I live there and he goes
you want to cheat on your taxes I go we
I mean you know I just yeah be cool man
I'm not technically saying that but he
goes so what do you want to do and I
I'll buy a place or maybe rent a place
and he goes and pretend you live there
oh yeah he goes that's cool and so you
want to cheat on your taxes you can tell
me yeah I go yeah he goes and and you
you you're a food guy right so the food
in jail is bad so and I go no I don't
want to go to jail because I know and
what makes you think that you get away
with that I'm just curious yeah you're
so funny everybody else and he goes
because you know they check your credit
card and they check your phone and they
check all that stuff they can trace
where you've been uh I know guys that
get around that sure they have family
out there and they put the phone and
address in their name and the credit
cards go ahead they have them use it
hope it's worth it when you get caught
and then you have to pay all that back I
know a lot of people get away with it
but it's just to me it's scary too I'd
be terrified it's too scary no because
you do get caught ooh Daddy yeah now you
and I travel enough we're out of La
enough
where where you could make a case that
the majority of my business is done
elsewhere
stuff not with a podcast that was a
podcast right yeah
is that it chin that's it I gotta pee so
bad before we do anything else all right
go be
um what do you got for this weekend
so I'm out for UFC 288 yeah we're doing
a live Cowboys fight campaign with Ryan
Garcia George Janko and a very special
guest so that 7 P.M Pacific Live on
YouTube it's gonna be a fun one uh some
good fights will be going down UFC 288
uh mostly excited for my boy Steamroller
Matt Steamroller is the main event on
the prelims against uh Drew Dober who I
also love Chrome Gracie I'll take Crone
I'm taking all dogs here so I'm taking
Matt Steamroller taking Chrome Gracie
I'll take uh Muhammad and I'll take aljo
Al Jermain Sterling would you take him
you're taking Muhammad over Gilbert yes
like that they're all dogs I'm taking
the dogs yeah who you gotta be uh I'm
going you're taking algeman overseer
yeah why
I don't like the three-year layoff for
cejudo uh at cejudo's age if you look at
the odds the guys at his age and title
fights are like one in 60. it's not good
really yeah how old is now 36. whoa so
anyone 36 and over they're like 1 in 16
years much smaller than algerman isn't
he no no no same weight class Al
Jermaine's taller though uh-huh they got
one Championship which I'll be at in
person seeing our boy Mikey mucho Messi
yeah Rod Tang you got DJ in the trilogy
fight against Marias stamp fair tax
salt ditch also doing the damn thing you
got Sage Northcutt rdr's fighting it's a
good card man I'll be in person for that
one are you taking for the for the
fights though I got um I got sehudo
just because he's a slight favorite I
just hate betting he's just such a beast
he's just different cloth and then
um I have uh balal
yeah I like below's chances against
Gilbert
uh Bryce Mitchell most most are moves
are moves are that sounds like he's a
wrestler yeah he is he's 20-0 yes it's a
tough matchup for Brian to go with it
moves are I'm rooting for Bryce Flat
Earth Mitchell get it done yeah I I just
tend to go with anybody with the last
name with a V and I'm just like what's
his name mozvar mofsar avlove thank God
Muhammad and Gilbert Burns got out of
this card because before that this card
was get off can I get uh color on
Charles jourdain
great Striker this old school Striker
versus grandma no you got to go with
Grappler just go back to your roots and
yeah Crone hasn't fought since he fought
uh Swanson Swanson Cub Swanson he lost
Cub Swanson he's fought what 2019. yeah
it's just he gets a whole 19. if you get
to hold you yeah now the gentleman he's
fighting Charles jourdain he he's also
following tough times too I think he's
lost three in a row two in a row okay so
he's two out of his last four yeah three
he's lost three hours last five so it's
not a terrible fight for Crone I'm in
for Chrome's my guy yeah
tough fight though
okay
there we go all right kids that's it
enjoy the fights tune the fight
companion 7 P.M Pacific live on thick
Boy again Ryan Garcia George Janko
myself and a very special guest will be
throwing down throwing back some tiger
thick jacked up on Kratom doing the damn
thing 7 P.M live on thick boy YouTube
UFC 288 calabas fight companion what are
you gonna be be I'll be this weekend at
um
Port Charlotte the vasani theater and
then I got Stress Factory we're back to
Thursday May 11th May 12th May 13th it's
Thursday Friday Saturday come get some
it's going to be a blast
uh touring wise for me we just announced
that we'll get it added today May 19th
I'm at the Ice House shop and friends we
have Jeff dye some other funny people on
there with myself one show only I think
the eight o'clock show that's on a
Friday at the Ice House May 19th and
I'll be doing spots around La in May and
then uh the tour starts back up uh June
2nd through the 4th that's a Friday
Saturday Sunday Comedy Store La Jolla
right outside San Diego and then I jump
over to the pond Belfast June 15th one
show in every city one theater show
theater run so Belfast June 15th Glasgow
June 17th Glasgow Manchester June 18th
London June 22nd Cardiff June 23rd and
we end the trip in Europe in Dublin June
25th tickets at thickboy.com love it all
right kids love you be safe we're out